continental tire coaches corner will
talk to Tom Thibodeau the timberwolves
new head coach I'm guaranteeing they
make the playoffs next season yeah I'm
gonna put the pressure on coach I don't
have to worry about it 877 3dp show
email address DP Dan Patrick com we will
get to your best and worst of the
weekend mclovin will have a poll
question as well but let's bring in the
coach who joins us now Tom how are you
I'm doing great time thanks for Adam are
you okay I just guaranteed you're making
the playoffs hahaha nothing like a
little pressure I'm doing fine though I
if you look at this series now with
clean if you're Cleveland right now what
do you what do you do what do you say
how do you try to stop this flood this
Avalanche yeah well you know obviously a
Golden State handled their business at
home so now I think Cleveland goes back
home they have to regroup I think they
have to analyze you know how they're
giving up these points and you know in
against Golden State two or three a two
or three bad minute period can open up
the game very quickly against you so in
Game one I thought they played well
enough to win at the end of the third
quarter that game was very winnable
obviously game two was a lot different
and they got control of the game and I
think right now the depth of Golden
State is really wearing on them and now
when they go home they have to figure
out defensively what they have to do to
try to limit some of those threes but
Golden State is a great passing team and
when you look at the way that Iguodala
and Livingston and Bogut what they're
doing with their playmaking is putting a
lot of pressure on them and then of
course Barbosa has been very very
efficient in a low amount of minutes so
they're getting a terrific all-around
play from their bench I think when you
look at Cleveland right now I mean
obviously Kevin Love going out early in
the game hurt them some in Kyrie
but they got to get their bench guys and
usually that's the case when they go
home the bench will play a little bit
better but they're going to need a
better all-around game to have a chance
to win how do playoff blowouts happen I
mean these are supposed to be the two
best teams coach yeah and i think you
know you're seeing more of that now in
you know you saw it in the UH in the
conference finals as well you know I
think part of that is you know they use
is a three-point shot a bad minute in a
game can cost you ten points very
quickly so I think how you cover the
wine how you control the ball and then
you know sometimes to reduce the
three-point attempts you tend to go to
more switching with that which then
leads thought the offensive rebounding
and the kick-out three which is a you
know not now that you know your
compounding errors and a game can run
away from you very quickly but I you
know I think that Cleveland is a
terrific team I think you're going to
see a different team when they go home
you have gotten you know gone around the
country around the world looking at
different styles and coaches love to
borrow from other coaches you know we
see what D'Antoni did in Phoenix is
probably a little bit of what Golden
State does or Gregg Popovich and what he
did in San Antonio is the NBA going to
start I mean you don't have steph curry
or klay Thompson nobody does but the the
style and the use of the three-pointer
how does that change now as we move
forward with the success of the Warriors
well I think when the the rule change
changes came into play it changed the
game as you can recall from the 90s it
was more of a power game people were
playing power forwards at the small
forward position it was very physical
and I thought the league made a good
decision to try to open it up but it
probably did cross over the line and
then it brought more skill into the game
so now you're seeing a lot of teams that
are playing small forwards at the power
forward position there's much more of a
premium on the three but in many ways I
don't think the game has changed
because teams had have to play to their
strengths and you cover up your
weaknesses and when you look at pop pop
has changed this file many times he you
know was a power coach defensive guy
with David Robinson and Tim Duncan then
he shifted with the guards with when
David retired Tim started getting older
he went more towards Parker Ginobili and
then of course when Kawhi came there he
changed again with with Aldridge it's
back to more of a power game but I think
that's what you know good coaches will
doing when you look back and you can go
way back and look at Don Nelson Don
Nelson was more of a defensive type of
guy in Milwaukee people tend to forget
that and then he you know he went out
west in with Golden State and he opened
up the floor and then when he went to
Dallas he you know we with nashi did the
same thing there and of course what Mike
did with D'Antoni did with Phoenix you
see a lot of different styles and I
think that's what makes the game so
great you know you can win different
ways i think what Golden State is doing
now is very unique you see the the
composition or their roster makes them a
very unique they start big they can play
real big and then they can downsize in
place mall and then when they do go
small though they're not really small
because of the size that they have with
Iguodala and Livingston and you know the
versatility to switch and they don't
sacrifice their defense that's the one
thing that probably has gotten
overlooked and how good their defense is
and it's been that way for a couple of
years now in you know they're scoring a
lot of points but they're defending
extremely well also and you can't
overlook that it's Tom Thibodeau the
timberwolves new head coach joining us
Stan Patrick so why even go back to Jack
Ramsey portland trail blazers they react
with i mean there have been a lot of
instances where we've seen this wide
open style of offense even Jack when he
was with the Buffalo Braves with McAdoo
and Ernie DiGregorio and Randy Smith
getting out and running I think the 90s
did a lot of damage to basketball that
it was slowing
sumo wrestling and now all of a sudden
we look at Golden State and people like
oh my god this is incredible i said
basketball used to be that way believe
it or not guys made the extra pass and
that's what i noticed last night they
make the extra pass and you don't have
this me ball and that's it's contagious
i really do i think it's contagious with
that team well then i think you're
hitting on something big and you're
right the fast-break has been a big part
of the game for a long time dating back
to Red Auerbach you know and and all
those great teams but the passing I
think when you when you look back at all
the great teams they'll all been great
passing teams you mean you look at the
championship teams with the Knicks they
were great passing teams in and that's
what makes this team so good when you
look at the skill set of an Andre
Iguodala who's basically a point guard
dream on same thing Bogut terrific pass
or Livingston great size playmaking
ability and they're all in selfish like
clay in stuff are very unselfish they'll
pass up a great shot you know to you
know get someone a layup you know and
and of course the way they shoot in the
way they move without the ball they keep
constant pressure on you at all times
and they're going to make you pay for
mistakes so I think how you pressure the
ball is critical how you read the ball
where you direct the ball all those
things are vital and if one guy's not
making multiple efforts you're going to
be in trouble you're going to give up an
open shot the difference between a
Chicago winter in a Minnesota winter is
what not much so well-prepared but do
you want to tell your family like this
is it one of those it you know lifestyle
changes where you know Chicago's is a
great city what that that when that wind
whips off the lake there a Minnesota is
just cold Chicago has different degrees
of cold i would think depending on the
winds coming off the lake no you're
right the end they were in chicago we
could get pretty nasty there in the
middle of the winter so when when the
winds blown off that Lake you don't want
to be you know outside for sure in the
same probably holds true here
was here once before so I know it can
get cold but hopefully it's cold for the
opponent you inherit karl-anthony towns
and andrew wiggins like sometimes when
you go into a coaching situation there's
a reason why you're going into a coach
the coaching situation I love this
situation here and having those two
stars you got Zach Lavine maybe you get
a three point shooter their little depth
there and you're off to the races so the
biggest concern taken over Minnesota is
what well I think you hit on I think we
have the best encore in the league
obviously we have a lot of work to be
done we need to improve our shooting I
think we need to improve our toughness
obviously the defense needs a lot of
work but the West is tough so there's
you know there's a there's going to be a
lot of work that has to be done a
commitment has to be made on both sides
of the ball you have to be consistent I
think you have to put the work in each
and every day you've got to be doing the
right things and then we have to be
well-balanced we want to be strong on
both sides of the ball but when you look
at the best teams in the league that's
what they are and that's what we're
going to strive for great to talk to you
coach good luck and once again when you
make the playoffs you can remember that
you heard it here first I beg to be up
thanks for having me on all right let's
Tom Thibodeau they call him mr. Tibbs
he's got good pipes by the way yeah
Jesus and you might you know when your
coach and you have those pipes and then
you get mad and you yell at people you
probably get their attention but to
young team they're gonna play defense
you're all in on your night while I do
like him I I do like him cuz I like
towns like Karl Anthony towns was legit
and Wiggins I love him too Zach Lavine
we can kind of corral him so he's not
just a dunker I don't know about Rubio
got to get a three-point shooter in
there at least one or two but uh no
it'll be be fun be fun to watch them
continental coaches tire wait
Continental Tire coaches corner there it
is what did I say continental coaches
tire something like that something like
that but it's a coach's corner brought
to you by Continental tires what I meant
to say from sunday rain to snow and
everything in between Continental Tire
has engineered of tire
for what you do they want you the driver
to have the traction performance and
comfort you require on any road you
travel so Continental Tire engineering
tires with extraordinary performance and
reliability putting confidence into
driving for more info the location of a
dealer near you visit Continental Tire
com Continental Tire for what you do the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]